hey both thanks so much for your work
i've been puzzling for a while why there
are almost zero woke debates held
anywhere
you'd think they would want to get their
messages out thanks tim
they can't do it though they'd be
terrible at it um
yeah they it is inherently a
terrible position because the thing is
um
maybe debate is the wrong term but a
dialectic is predicated on the idea that
there is some truth to discover and
wokeness is predicated
on the idea that there isn't and so it's
a it's a mismatch
um i will sooner uh want to engage in
sword fighting of course they i'm sure
they can't do that either
right um yes yes no doing things is not
their strong suit
but destroying things doing things and
thinking things both
not so much right so i will point people
again to the
um the braver angels podcast with
john wood jr and um
bob woodson and i don't know this is
duke newsom
i don't know i hope i have it right i
hope i have not embarrassingly pulled a
name from somewhere else
i've done that before here well i i hope
i didn't but in any case
if you look for bob woodson you will
find i think it's
duke newsom as the counterpart and
there is a very good debate between a an
idw
style uh person in bob woodson
and duke on the other side as
a high up in blm and john wood jr
as moderator and it does give you a
sense for how these things go and i must
say
um it goes about as as you would expect
well i mean interestingly actually our
introduction to john wood jr was
when he moderated a debate um put on by
the
bridging the divide i think it's called
organization
um based here in portland uh between us
and to people who were representing the
the woke side
and um there is audio and poor quality
video of that
too um somewhere out there in the world
um
and i mean john it it was our
introduction to john he's he's
extraordinary as a moderator in that
sort of situation
and uh you know doesn't let anyone sink
but
uh lets people sink themselves when when
that's what's going to happen
when that is warranted yes
[Music]